okay so I put on the blackboard two
famous quotes not the most famous loss
to the two things question with Thomas
Hobbes and the reason I put these on
blackboard
is there going to be a stark contrast
between what Hobbes is doing with ethics
and what we've been looking at so far
although you will recognize some
people's ideas like for silliness you'll
see certificates kind of reflected in
Hobbes so think back to Plato very first
discussions we were engaged in this is
one of the things he says he talks about
a general inclination of all mankind
human come to a perpetual and restless
desire of power after power that ceases
only with death if there is something
that he thinks is most basic to the
human condition
that's it so this is Hobbes's view of
human nature this is what we call his
anthropology as being a lot of the
things that we think of moral concepts
Hobbes just going to revalue who's going
to look at the very different life and
you may find us attractive where you may
find it repugnant or you may find it
irritating or you may find it but
there's somebody like myself does to be
in some ways very insightful and
I myself have done a lot of writing on
top quite a few pieces and got a lot of
conference presentations on Hobbes and
it's not because I agreed with Thomas
More's it's not because I think this is
actually true it's because I think this
is this reflects to some degree what
human nature can become when things go
wrong a bit more next class about the
state of nature
another quote you might have heard is a
life outside of authority or society is
nasty brutish and short
you ever hear that phrase nasty brutish
and short
yeah that's coming from Hobbs - that's
coming from what we're going to look at
next class this is how we get there this
is if this is true that what really
motivates us is seeking power after
power after power that's how we can get
to life big nasty brutish and short if
you don't have some sort of contract
area to keep us in check
here's the other one this is beautiful
what's the weapons the object of any
man's or woman's right problems not
gender-specific in that way and the
player desire then that isn't theirs he
for his particles good there are be a
nothing simply an absolutely soul nor
any common rule of good and evil
now if that's true we're in trouble and
we'll look at why he thinks that's the
case this is a very radical challenge to
all the other things that we've been
studying so far it's a very radical
challenge to the
study after pops doesn't mean that Hobbs
is actually right it just means that you
know if you want to pick somebody to be
you know the toughest villain possible
some people would say that that
Friedrich Nietzsche would be the person
to do I would say it's Thomas Hobbes
that's why we're going to look at that
we should couple class sessions in such
a interesting and deep challenge to the
notions that we normally work with a
write blog and the reason why can't you
do this writing down as many moral
concepts as you can think of it is I'm
going to put these on the board and see
you know where the passes and then we'll
actually talk about which one's Table
three values which when Hans is going to
change studying so far and what you may
feel in your hearts with you made them
brought up with what you may have
thought up until this point I'm I'm not
actually hoping that any of these the
bathroom committed Hodgins that might
actually be a bad thing in some ways but
I would like you daily sense the death
of the challenge
so Babel with them well some people put
people up here and then wouldn't be
quite the same as concepts of that's
good but they also put the analogy
and I guess you could call them all
concept right so actually it's like a
bunch of all concepts put together
that's very good pleasures desires
rationality epithets sir Quran of room
on earth
okay won't be filled up a tiny portion
of the board and this was after asking
you just for a minute to write stuff
down
so actually you should feel pretty proud
of yourself as a class this is the stuff
that you know ethics is made of these
are the concepts this is the vocabulary
and you guys did that acquirement
something were able to recall more I
think if I set you down on offer you
know these 5-10 minutes most likely most
of you would come up with a list this
one that is one thing led to thinking
about another thing that's good that's
the way that we think about things and
you know that with these things not
everybody sees things the same way like
let's say we take the highest good if
somebody is what we call the hedonist
what do they think the highest good is
no they're a hedonist yeah this is
something that we touched on but yeah
pleasure pleasure
very good comes from the Greek word for
pleasure and you know we saw some
reflections of this attitude we didn't
see anyone like a spouse to get straight
out we saw the RX level talking about
this the hedonistic lifestyle I said
yeah we like pleasure but that's not the
best thing yeah so evenness thinks that
the highest food is pleasure
what does aerosol think the highest food
is
it was kind of complicated or a couple
of things all together
what's the corner though forgiving him
it's one of the things that's up here
yeah there would be one part of that
moderation is a virtue a very good what
if you're through sickness what do you
think the highest and high as good is
Paula very good Thomas Hobbes is saying
there is no such thing there is no high
step
period there's only higher ends for
different people and that changes from
time to time there is nothing in the
nature of things that you know produces
the highest end for us all we have are
the things that we pursue along the way
and you know because human beings are
more of us similar to each other
we didn't make some generalizations but
your highest dad may not be the same
things her highest them there's a matter
of fact your highest end right now may
be very different than your highest end
two hours from now
or you know twenty years ago
these are all theories Tom's house is
not gonna talk about theories so much
but he is gonna talk about all these
different concepts and so he's gonna
talk about happiness in a very different
way than they are style or Thomas or
Plato did we're not reading of the areas
where he talks about religion but Hobbes
is actually a very skeptical guy that
comes to religion except religion
originally has its origin and it became
a big Spears of the unknown and he's got
a whole sort of theory about how this
gets blown up into big organized
religions that's one of the other
chapters if you want to read it he looks
at honor in a very different way than
played over here so those CIN Hobbes
does not worry so much about that he
says well I first you have to have a
lawgiver and then you can worry about
sin you're gonna see that he looks at
reason and virtue advice and very
precise if you really think that there
is no rule for good and evil that it's
just sort of whatever people happen to
come up with in this place or that place
what do you think happens the ideas of
virtues and vices remember virtue is
something good kappa that produces good
stocks consistently and vices
some things bad habit that produces bad
things consistently there's a whole
longing of good and bad it's up for
grabs what happens
we might not even have the same
categories of virtue and biases somebody
else think about you know a more violent
Society for their own think about
Afghanistan
nobody's successfully Afghanistan
including Afghans we've never been a
long-term successful government of
Afghanistan and people fight each other
over all sorts of reasons what might be
a virtue there what do you think they
look up to a really tough guy be willing
to kill people you know what you need to
does that something you guys promise
anybody here you know once almost
psychopathic killers thinks that's the
best thing that you could be in our
society we do have some segments of our
society where that's the case right
criminal underworld prisons California
prison system if you can put it to the
California prison system run my games
and you wanted to survive you probably
should actually be as violent and crazy
as possible that's probably the only way
to make it true just here in the Indiana
prison system you can make through a lot
of this you know varies from
circumstance and circumstance
how does onto something if you don't
actually have a strong well rooted sense
of right where are you going to get all
these ideas from how are you going to
work
I think all of you know people who use
this kind of language they live up to it
yeah you know people who talk about you
know doing the rational thing and you
watch them they're pretty irrational or
they're only they're only rational when
it serves their interests and then when
it comes to laying and doing the right
thing from you or somebody else that you
think is important suddenly you know
we're you know we're susceptible to
incredible variance and if you don't
have these sort of concepts pretty well
rooted in your psyche you may end up
looking like the hot kind of individual
remember what Aristotle talked about the
person who lacks self-control they can
look a little bit like lighthouses ideas
they may have you know just conflicted
desires we're going to do what they
think is the right thing but it's really
not that compelling for them because
they don't do the right thing they do
something else instead
maybe because pleasure masters never
hang their masters so
Hobbes is going to put all these things
through a wringer and they're going to
come out looking very different in the
end so let's let's actually take a look
at what he does
I'm going to raise
what would you say well
oh so most most basic as in most
importance we're most simple maybe like
the ones that we could we can say we
need to use all the time
what are we ultimately trying to do
thinking about ethics we're trying to
say something about something yeah yeah
I think those are probably the most
basic dirty either right or wrong
right how do we know what's what you
actually get in bed remember at the
beginning of the semester we did that
sort of tablet of or two things you
think are good or things you think are
bad pleasure alongside peanut the other
family well family that's straddle both
sides we do have a bad family that say
abuses have them while you're here
successful with the beatings yeah good
and bad good a good manner good and evil
right along these seem to be the most
basic concepts Hobbs doesn't start out
with these Hobbs is going to move
towards these four Hans the most basic
idea is that everything is material and
so you know he's got some strange ideas
and we trip if yes ma'am Hobbs about God
you know because he safely says that he
believes we got it actually this is this
is the Leviathan the whole thing and
when you're reading are just little
slivers of it the second half of the
book is all devoted in theology so
sort of God but you know how do you get
God in the picture if you're a complete
materialism everything is just touch see
feel matter right even mine if you're a
materialist what do you think your mind
is your brain so take your brain out and
do some of these science fiction things
we take this restores his brain out that
mr. Cohen was brain into mr. Schwartz is
call and I'll forget all the you know
tricky stuff that would be involved in
that and we'd swap which of course is
graded mr. Cohen's call and now you know
we'd have to call him mr. Cohen mr.
Schwartz is his personality who he is
would be in this body and your
personality would be an antibody that's
those are certain implications of
materialism there's no soul there's no
spirit or anything like that
now if you're materialist what do you
actually have to work with get me at her
because one can matter there's another
can matter put together in different
ways and what can matter take on I can
take on different shades different
configurations like this is a plastic
you know plastic is is pretty
complicated where this comes from
ultimately we're thinking about fossil
fuels something that we burn somebody
goes into making plastics you make
plastics other than it's too late for
most of us made out of oil and these are
really complex molecules together
remember chemistry class right simple
things like chalk or salts remember what
salt was so what did chloride sodium
okay it's more complicated when you got
you get organic things like like plastic
then you got something you're made of
even more complicated but it's really
just a matter put together in different
ways and think about your body your
body's really complicated doesn't look
that complicated from the outside and if
you're not if you don't really know what
you're doing and you open it up it
doesn't look that complicated don't cut
yourself then you ever have any head cut
we didn't actually see like what's
underneath can't grow something out some
people have vessels well what if you
looked at it under a microscope you
remember back in biology class and I did
you guys have like a freshman here or
sophomore year what did you guys have a
biology
what was your body composure I really
did you do that thing when you take a
little drop of blood and you put it on
the slide look at what did you get it
look at what you do it's not that long
ago do you remember anything from before
you just trying to get through it
did you dissect frogs or pigs or cats or
something but what's the human body
composed you don't have to remember
biology class at all this is basic
knowledge what do you mean ask my my son
this wants it said we're made of blood
and then go around for a lot say Danny I
made a blood your made-up lot you know
it's okay after a while it gets but
that's the you know the three and he had
a lot of uniforms and
Sallis right each one of those cells
when you look at it under microscope was
this simple no it's it's made up of a
whole bunch of other things and now put
together together in the right way what
happens let's say for instance you know
the you know the way things turn out
your hearts over here being up here does
that kind of work I don't know they did
get good I'm not a scientist but
probably not or if it hurts too big if
you're small but it's only got three
ventricles isn't for ventricles
the veins are doing the wrong ways or
what happens when the veins get blocked
so somebody a stroke you get a stroke
and then either you're gonna live
impaired are you're gonna die and that's
the way of organisms are think about it
your body you know like you said a
complex set of systems all connected to
each other you've got a circulatory
system down these tiny capillaries well
what's wrong in these different ways you
have a gastrointestinal system you have
so you can consume food and actually get
something out of it you have nerves
going into all these different parts
your body you have skeleton and all
those things are our material right
that's why scientists can know something
about them do these amazing things with
medicine so you have structure you've
got a matter and then what else about
matter is important what moves your
blood stops moving what's very happy
it will stop moving at one point for
each one of us you're vaporized
what's going to be when will that be
when you're dead your blood stops moving
that's it what happens period nerves not
transmitting electrical impulses your
your dad that's it you know your
narratives are constantly transmitting
electrical impulses if they didn't he
wouldn't breathe and your heart would be
and nothing else will take place so all
of that has to be going out but in fact
even like you know your GI tract has to
be constantly doing stuff girl so you're
gonna die to stop with this death for a
physical organism it's not just shark
stops swimming it dies that's actually
true does anybody know if that's
actually true okay
something about the water going over its
gills but for a human being sure Hobbs
what's the most basic is motion anything
except the way that we're put together
we have all these different motions
going in on all the time and we're not
all that aware of what's going on inside
of ourselves none of you like God this
morning it's all right now I get start
breathing heaven of breathing breathing
about for sleeping but now I make myself
take more breaths right when you start
running you save yourself all right how
long's breathe more you don't do that
right most of this is unconscious is
happening below the level of your
awareness
top six that's the case with the things
that you desire and the things that you
turn away from as well that most of the
things that we feel towards
that way and he talks about emotion is
this something he calls endeavor that
endeavor means you know trying to strive
it trying to get towards something but
he talks about three basic conditions
one is what he calls appetite and where
do we see this term before number Plato
appetites what do you know the appetites
for such food
all of us have the same basic appetites
we get hit you don't do them some of
them you'll buy water from its food what
else do you want to do your what's your
body my dear sweet you have you don't
sleep after a while you go the same your
body will break down and then let's see
you what's the other thing one have sex
yeah ok and now that you've passed the
interview two videos basically on candy
now there's everything you are all
emotions that you have through the
motions of your heart your soul are they
all sports tents no there's some that
are shine a bright light in your eyes do
you like that what are you naturally
trying to do what if I just keep poking
you why would you want to do that
because you don't like being poked right
I don't think anyone's like like
something poking
and I'm not behind you in the light of
the cafeteria and while I'm waiting in
line I just figured skinny couple folks
you wouldn't like that
what are some other things you don't
like they reversed you actually like
bodily turn away from other noises you
don't like yeah like the fire alarm goes
off in your dorm at 3 in the morning and
then you got to go outside to summon
some jerk hold it because we were drunk
and then you go outside and the
weather's like this now what man is a
complex emotion do you feel like
modeling yeah what does you don't want
to be there right you naturally Canada
turn away with what if you're what it's
the opposite it's too hot Goldilocks
your body wants to get away from that
too right feels pain so we got appetite
and aversion and there's something else
as possible too
and that's what Hobbes calls contempt
and you've been worded a little bit
different way than we normally do what
contempt means is not feeling appetite
or aversion towards it just not caring
about it at all and it's not just
because you don't care about at all it's
because you actually feel the apathetic
aversion towards other things you're
feeling these all the time but you may
not for instance care about my coffee I
do care about my pocket I doubt it
alright this is my coffee and it's
really don't concern of yours now if you
wanted my coffee
what a battle before it then you are
feeling the epithet for it if I force my
coffee on here and I say take this
drinkin and he said I don't want to do
that you're feeling a version right they
can think about when you were a kid I
love this is Gavin Juba yet the other
drank beer you probably or maybe your
mom they would have to go to the
refrigerator and get beer for though
this is also kind of lazy never like
open it and take a sip when you're a
little kid you don't try it again after
that because it tastes awful because
your taste buds are not or not
acclimated
you don't enjoy the taste you wonder
this you know 18 19 years old
of course 21 here because of the laws
these ones actually change their
physical taste buds modify and bitter
things start to become good tasting to
you and things that you didn't like
before you start trying again defined
you like them this fits in what Hobbs is
talking about things that you are averse
to before you now mine enjoyable yeah
pop great system for there when the
object that you feel Appetit where it is
absent we call that desire and his
presence we call it law so Hans would
say when you're eating that chocolate
bar you love that chocolate you're
feeling lost
when the object is not present that you
Jesus trying to version or words that
you reverse - let's take the air for let
me who ever teach that some really
bitter harvest out fear and you don't
like it I like myself but I remember was
kind of interested me I like to drink
Guinness Extra Stout and I had this my
birria see some of you feel aversion
towards it and I just have to mention
that it's not present and yet we could
do a whole I don't want that
apparently in Liberia they make young
men drink it - I can't prove their
romantic because they don't like the
taste of them a lot of other crazy thank
you when the object is your presence
what do you feel that paint so you can
do this with people - you know there's
some people that rub you the wrong way -
not around your worst of it they're
round again now this is very this is
very different use of lava King than
what we're used to
you've been a psychology yeah here's
where it gets even more interesting
whatever the person was either their
loves they call it good so get us extra
stopped I think it's good I feel desire
for it when I have it going and I have
love for it drinking this garnett the
wonder of the strongest was visible
reaction against the class she actually
feels a burst towards it and if I wasted
on her she hates that she would say that
it's bad or that gives us evil we don't
even call beer we call people
all right and if you just go contempt
for something can you call it quiet or
insurance doesn't matter all you have
known that it feels like when somebody
treats me with contempt right
they don't even heat you they don't
that's all forces yeah the reason behind
denial
it's a good question do you mean like
etymologically or generally pop you're
right pops is using them for things that
we don't have feelings no it's the way
that they affect other people if I have
contempt for your pop stinks that you're
gonna take that as because remember that
we all want power we all want to be
valued and if we don't give it and
contempt is the really like it if I hate
you you know right if I treat you with
contempt then you can really become as
many you might say people hate being
treated with contempt but you're right
the contempt by itself isn't either a
lot more hey it's so we have a good and
evil vile or insignificant and Hamas's
made to break this down even further
there's different ways in which things
are good
remember Aristotle talked about this
with the friendship stuff
there's the friends who are good because
there
useful pops if they have some good
things we say that they're good
he has Mises they're useful right like
this beer if you're drinking it each day
because you think that it's going to
improve your health probably do they say
one you know glass of red wine let's say
it was that it would be useful the
opposite of that is harmful that's one
of the way things are bad right to drink
12 beers today that's probably harmful
probably hurtful multiple ways it's not
good for the end of being a good
physical health it's not good for the
end holding down a job there are some
people I think
now then what other ways thanks to me
what other ways are talking member
platte the friendships pleasure there
are some good things that are delightful
or expose it right
what's the opposite of that what's the
absolute pleasure hateful or disturb
mmm you wouldn't guess this and there
are things that we call beautiful and
things that we call ugly Acosta
something really interesting about these
who says that's good or evil in the
promise why do we think that beautiful
things are beautiful well because we
think that they're going to bring us
pleasure why do they think that ugly
things are ugly they are likely to bring
us displeasure this is a particular way
of looking at good and bad it's a little
bit hard to to get this with some things
that makes sense like think about the
attractiveness of good bodies alright or
what you find attractive and other
people if you find them attractive you
probably think you don't their timing
right if you find them ugly you probably
think you wouldn't have a good time
when you talk about being ugly on the
inside outside
all the sort of stuff but they're sort
of a promise there I would play around
you can think about that with food too
right that's why they were watching any
of you watch those food shows a hair
shaft or top shaft for that plating is
very important even though plating
doesn't affect the way the food tastes I
think air about that so they saw
non-functional garnish because it sort
of promises this is going to be an
enjoyable experience for you maybe
somebody just throws a bunch of stuff
together on the plate in my bag thank
you sir there are some people who get
their thirst for food of any mix it all
together but ugliness isn't this sort of
a promise of history
yeah and now numbness these beard he's
totally very according to the person
who's feeling up towards the object so
we just appear as an example let's do
something else let's think about music
how many of you
well it's just shy what kind of music do
you like to listen there's so many
different genres it's not anything what
do you like okay how many of you are
like okay what's up classical how many
other notice not the same people right
there is some overlap what are they all
right how many people in our country but
not just any kind of battle I'm knew
about all nineteen eighties power miles
from the hate it
no notice - you can break these things
down into different genres there's when
it comes to rap there's all these
different genres one time those East
Coast versus West Coast that there's
southern rap and all these different
things we both look into our music
project you can see all these different
types of things then where does it react
and it hip-hop again that's one of the
perennial questions right and now a hip
hop can mean anything in life please
when I was a kid it meant something very
specific and like my fiance isn't she
doesn't mean anything that well that's
kind of a Hobbesian think anything can
mean anything into the person who
likewise with things like good evil
right wrong beautiful ugly all these
sorts of things are gonna vary according
to the person who's feeling for so many
other class well doc oh yeah the
comments and then it's hard it does that
mean seventies eighties yeah now it's
kind of funny because on some stations
they'll say for meeting classic rockers
of sixties seventies and early eighties
and now they'll put stuff from the 90s
they call that classic dry would it make
sense because you don't for that is
before your time Amon he has the same
sort of function that to the Eagles
different so a lot of these things are
very relative looks like Bob's is almost
a relativist when it comes to values now
maybe that's not a problem maybe that's
okay which is you know if she's one of
us has our own thing I think that that
tomatoes are you know the best thing in
the world and you think that God is the
best thing I can't we all just get along
you know I think that we should send
more money overseas per foreign aid
different videos you know be valuing
things differently I think that it's
okay that it's actually a lot of fun
it's delightful to torture people you
don't you don't get into their no we're
starting to get into a problem right if
I have things that I think are good and
you think that they're actually bad
what's gonna happen to us
what's that we could argue yeah that's
not the way it always works let's have a
monkey we're gonna wear it in the album
I'm a pretty big guy you know I'm not a
good shape but let's have it done and
you know just came out of a clog or
something like that and kind of come to
the entire and I put a gun to your belly
and I say give me your money
you could argue with me to say and you
see that as a good thing I see that as a
bad thing here's why I think it's a bad
thing that were
if I'm already being if I'm already sort
of in motion based on my views on what's
good or if they had a renter on my
epithets of moving me actually a friend
did in fact bargain with Walker
she was that part of Milwaukee on the
beach a guy came up to her he had a
knife and said give me your money then
she actually you know shouldn't have a
wallet machine she cursed or something
she said well I'm gonna give you the
money I'm not committed a curse because
it's gotten a credit card and I'm not
going to spend the time canceling those
credit cards because that's Pam I'm not
giving you my ID because it takes a long
time to get a new ID especially if you
don't have ID handy I'll give you the
money but the rest of it I'm not going
to give you if you want to you know do
something based on that I'm just letting
you know right out of it you know you
can have the [ __ ] like 80 bucks 80 bucks
then walk away where you can you know do
what you're gonna do is probably get on
fight before you probably good but I
think I entered 80 bucks takes a lot of
guts but a very smart thing in summer
strikes but most people who want what
you have can't actually parking they're
dead set up or you know think about how
their apartment notions of right law
they're willing to fight with each other
and if you think that somebody else has
a radically different notion of right
along with you that means they're
dangerous to you you can't trust them
you can't depend on them you don't know
what they would stop and do next this is
the hot seat this is where we get into
stuff like because discussions with our
and now notice all of the emotions that
we have hops things can be broken down
into these basic things these basic
drives he talks about all these isn't in
the chapter 10 talks about power worth
dignity honor and worthiness it says the
power of a person is that their means to
obtain some future of character do it
and then it talks about all these
different modes of the power how do we
actually have time we want to have power
right why do we want to empower because
we want good days and power is what lets
us get good things you may not be used
to thinking of things in this way but
what happens when you go into the
restaurant what do you want to do in the
restaurant the other two dance go there
to watch the game it might be that it's
not going to be there when you go to a
restaurant and eat so you have an
appetite you want to eat anything
whatever they put in front of you there
are a few people not you have some
particular things that you want to eat
you want to be delightful you may be
beautiful
what are you gonna do that stuff
you don't just you know like wait your
hands who's there
but SDM restaurants it invited it to
front-of-the-house backgrounds who's in
the back of the house
the chef is the person in charge and
then there's like a whole army of people
underneath them you go there cook that
you know the borders come in who takes
the orders in front of those people
right who seats you later a hostess
maitre d somebody like that now you're
sitting at the table you're not gonna be
happy so it is to come over and start
talking it pretty soon who's that person
your server right how many of you have
ever seen a servant read before only a
few of them it happens every single day
most establishments somebody's gonna
treat the server my teacher and put off
the server is why did they do that well
because when you go into that restaurant
this is power and warrants that you have
in your wallet the more stuff you can
get
that restaurant you make people do what
you want them to do satisfy your needs
and we like them as a neck chopsticks is
a natural human thing to want to put
ourselves above other people and so on
people have lectures and restaurants
sometimes it's because they can and they
want to reinforce the idea that at least
for that moment they're superior to that
waiter or waitress yeah there are some
people who only know send food back to
the kitchen just to be jerks about just
because they can and this is the sort of
stuff goes on Pop's thinks that that's
actually more common than we would like
you think he makes it that's sort of the
norm but we'd want to have power over
each other so what happens when we're
friends of each other we're friends with
each other because we like the qualities
of other people but also because we want
to give something out of being friends
with this person friends are power think
back to high school and cliques because
there other cliques here and embarrassed
on campus students I don't know there
were at my college there were the
popular side that's going on about that
that's about power all right
some people are higher in the social
scale and what keeps them up there the
ability to dispense benefits of do you
want to be popular throw big parties
invite a lot of people over get them
liquored up do a nice boom in the
business world
yeah oh yeah I suppose social social
engagements I mean there's other ways
you know people are working for you know
power over the more people you have
working for you the more powerful you
are the more accounts you control the
more power you have more than important
person you are and Hobbs Thanks
deep down inside we all want power even
people who pretend like they don't want
power
you really do want power they just want
it in different ways they may have being
able to tell people what to do but they
want like being hooked up to Hopson
really inspired hop sticks were I'm also
what you have the crevices and what do
what do we want power the sort of things
that turn us on there are some things we
don't want people to have power over us
we don't like being pushed down in the
lower position we enjoy being on top we
don't like being a bummer
except for masochists masochist has
found some way to resolve this right but
pain and pleasure yeah he says you know
what is the value of the human being
this is pretty mercenary you know
somebody like Thomas Aquinas will say
every human being has value why because
they were created in the image of God so
even if they're a scumbag there's
something good something that summer top
says the value or worth of a human being
is as of all of the things their price
that is to say so much as would be given
for the use of their power that's the
only way that you can value human beings
in Hobbes field and he thinks that we're
doing this with each other all the time
so you know what what is my value to you
I can teach you something about ethics I
can be a gatekeeper for this class that
you have to take to get out and get out
of Maris College and onto your career I
could be entertaining I could be boring
you never knew their uses to any other
ways on my power is useful to you you're
useful meaning to the right and then
direct later paying my paycheck no I'm
not just here of sheer joy teaching
philosophy a new light
I enjoy actually interacting with
students discussing this notice this
work something for all of us doesn't but
if you look at it a bad way does it look
like we're engaged any sort of noble
Enterprise something that's worthwhile
and of itself what if I get burned out I
don't like teaching you guys anymore
the happens to professor's they don't
want to do anything
I got purged out as the student actually
by senior year I was totally burned I
couldn't wait to get out I'm so tired of
being stuck in classes
why don't you finish something else that
could happen you know okay you could
quit feeling all these warm fuzzy
feelings and start feeling some prickly
feelings towards learning philosophy
there's nothing to keep that from
happening in houses it's not like
philosophy by itself or doing good
actions by itself or anything like that
with automatic value towards the good
because what's the good hey it varies
from time to time to place to place the
glue only exists for a determinate human
beings so it's the same thing with the
value I had what do we do with people
that we value we honor them another
moral concept right honor and those
circles mr. Collins question about
contempt those who we value all we
dishonor them there's all different ways
in which we honor people in this honor
like asking somebody's opinion in
offices is to honor them it shows that
you care about what they thought not
asking their opinion maybe you want to
be asked and then that sends a message
doesn't what message is that so think
about if you've got a friend really
really close friend they meet somebody
out
there would you want them to talk to you
about it or not
maybe the way you look at friends expand
their dirt spots is there stuff I want
to be positive
unless let's make it a different one
let's say you're married now and your
spouse decides that it's time to sell
the house they didn't really ask you
about I think they haven't made the sale
because we actually design on that
property but they've already talked to
the real estate agent they've already
got all the deals lined up and one one
fine morning you're having a coffee
after breakfast on Saturday and the
company with paperwork today would you
mind signing this
I'm selling the house and we're gonna
move it how would you feel valued you
feel dishonored Hobbes's is talking
about precisely these sorts of things
and it's society it becomes very
dangerous because it's very easy when
you're honoring one person to dishonor
others is this is this is what's led to
the let's give everybody a prize
mentality because you know if we single
out one person as being really good at
something then everybody else feels bad
so I was a really good trumpet player
put her on a pedestal well if you do
that that everybody else down here it
kind of feels like they're they're being
Dishonored
so what we do is we create a trumpet
award then everybody gives us our does
that you guys some of you have been to
schools where that was the norm I think
right how do you feel when that happens
you feel like everybody's made enough to
this long enough yeah
yeah that's true they have often gets
left out of the decision-making process
because they think well you know they'll
all make it up there and then they'll
all feel good about themselves but when
you give everybody a few hours like that
what happens actually it all drops down
with the same one and now even succeeded
doesn't seem like a paraphrase somebody
who got in trouble recently so I'm
winning so that's that's honor then
house actually talks about what a close
managers and witnesses there's I'm not
talking about stuff like whether you
pick your teeth at the table already
know where a before I mean how we treat
each other in society those qualities of
mankind that can serve them living
together in peace and unity yeah so
there is no highest good there's nothing
that we can rely on to appeal to so how
can we probably keep people from
fighting each other how can we keep
people from wanting to do each other
again to compete with each other in such
ways that tear society and her says well
we got to look at human nature again and
what do all people all people they they
vary on what they call good all right so
what I think is good they not do the
same things you but you want to be able
to enjoy the things that you think are
good and you want to be left alone
to enjoy right you don't want to be
coming in okay that's enough good for
you now you're done or anybody else - I
want that too so if we can appeal to
balance that impulse to want to enjoy
whatever good it is that that we have
then with my people to work out without
us and this is where he starts talking
about is this Restless desire of power
after power if human beings really are
that way that we've got to find some way
to record their natural tendencies keep
them within certain bounds so they don't
hurt each other or kill each other or
steal from each other do all these
things that they don't want them to do
so what might make us what motives are
going to be appeal to can we appeal to
our higher motives you know it's a noble
thing to do that's not going to work
because they don't even agree about what
that is Wells can you appeal
what works
this is before so yeah I mean especially
for kids you know I know that there are
a lot of things that I didn't do that I
was tempted to do because I was afraid
of my dad my mom was no ordinary
disciplinarian and she was a pretty mean
to both those who like everybody on my
street was either spanked or beat and if
you've been spanked you know the
difference between spanking him either
there wasn't any of this sort of time
off business or something like that back
and my dad is just much more physically
strong so if he came home and I was
still in trouble it was that works well
and you can also trap people with you
know kind of hands while killing them
taking their stuff away putting in jail
what are you the peelings oh what a
motion somebody
here somebody who is close to Hobbs in
tight market militants want to say it
was better to be feared that the deal of
Hobbes thinks the same thing because
love is not reliable people change their
minds and they run all the time but if
you tell people look if you do this this
is going to happen to you you will stop
a few crazy people who do it anyway but
most of them will get in line and not if
I say the timbre of a society that's it
alright I'm in charge
none of you steal from each other
because if you do I'm going to cut your
hand off you're probably not as
definitely special if you see somebody
do it their hand gets got always curious
about this guy that's what we're going
to leave walk because that's going to
lead us into Pops's state of nature and
then it's solution to this part is is
cops beautifully these are going to feed
it ever good weekend